they just started high-fiving each other
talking mad for me yo my little
cousin got balls my little cousins gee
my cousin he's scaring nobody Brooklyn
got the old Batman now
[Music]
[Applause]
I hope that their zanpakuto Stoops the
stages
please get up come on everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm from East New York you know and
and when you grow up in East New York
you tend to have a bit of an edge to you
you know I'm as an example of that this
past Thanksgiving you know my uncle came
up to me he's like yo Gaston you know
your father once stabbed somebody over
Snapple and then he just walked away
like you know that's how you end
conversations there's no more details I
want to that apparently people died with
fruit punch all the time but it occurred
to me that my father just never wanted
me to know that side of him you know he
was trying real hard to protect me and
he came up with this plan he decided you
know what I'm gonna buy a house for my
sister I'm gonna buy a next-door to my
other sister you know we could shield
him from the neighborhood and it was
smarter than I had my mom my dad my aunt
upstairs my aunt next door and together
they could kind of keep me from the
hoodlums in the area you know protect me
but the problem was is that my cousins
that lived upstairs in next door they
were the hoodlums in the area you know I
was I was five years old my cousin Tito
is 14 lived upstairs my cousin Carlos is
15 next door you know and it was a
challenge because they were all a
like teenage drug dealers are amazing
you gotta understand everyday I'm going
to school
these dudes teenage drug dealers a real
pro truancy they don't care about
schedules they don't do unless they
want to you know so I'm seeing this
every day and I wanted to take part but
I couldn't because Carlos and megiddo
got into this real shitty habit you know
of scan the out of me all the time
you know they had this like pale white
face masks with green hair look like the
Joker and they used to put it on and hop
up from behind walls and screaming my
face wasn't cool don't appreciate
laughing at that man they did this
relentlessly they was screaming my face
I'd run inside crying my mom will hug me
she'd tell my dad my dad did go outside
he'd scream at them to cut this and
they'd leave me alone for a couple of
weeks we had a system in this one off
for like a year you know and I was okay
with that but the problem is you know I
was about to turn six week of my
birthday lens during Halloween week you
know and my father believed two things
he said one I'm six years old he thought
that I should be able to handle these
things on my own and two they were 15 or
16 years old at this point they're still
young enough where they could get away
wearing masks so in the week where I
should be thrilled I'm getting older I'm
scared because my dad gave these two
gangsters carte blanche to scare the
out of me
Oh goddamn weak ain't cool despite
that I woke up in a good mood my mom
made pancakes crushing it in school - my
2+2 game is crazy
nobody was seeing me I felt good was
dressed up I walk out the apartment door
got to the front door to building you
know and me get those opening the door
for me because he lived upstairs Jesus
you know kind of early to cheer me up
say happy birthday little man say you
know you're being strangely polite today
even
I don't know what brought about this but
keep it up I like it and I walked out
the door
Cheerios then Carlos jumps out from
the side got the mask on skins on my
face he's like bold I'm like oh
now run inside screaming I hit the door
closing he laughs in the back or a happy
birthday I get inside my
mom hugs me my dad walks in from my side
he was waiting in the car and he said
what happened
and I'm like Carlos and McGee thought he
scared me and he's like yo men up here
do your business right it sound like
solid advice but that's we said about
everything say your pops out tie my shoe
man up and handle your business he's a
gangster one proverb you know and I'm
like yo pops I need your help here man
he's like what happened like Carlos and
megiddo they scared me how did he scare
you guess what he scared me with the
mask what kind of mask is it it's a joke
of masked pops you're not paying
attention to what's happening in these
streets I need your help I hear in my G
is real he's like calm down gas star
who's the choke is scared of I said that
man pops
she said why don't you be Batman so
that's a good idea and I believe
that in my heart he gave my mom
some cash went the city line for those
you know New York is sitting on is the
border of Brooklyn and Queens it's a
nice shopping area now but back then it
was a foot lock and a bunch of 99-cent
stores you know and we went out there to
buy a costume you know I got kids I
spent $65 this year on my son's costume
she could be Captain America it's
I told my wife from
spending $65 he better be captain man
for graduation
new year's day I want to see this
in rotation this is not what I got
though I got a plastic man she had a
white rubber band and went around lips
who's white so I look like I'll buy no
Batman or you you know but I pulled that
off I was proud you know next day I
woke up I walked outside and he scared
me and I go frost I ran inside crying my
mom grabbed me she said Gaston hold up
baby stick to the plan
I say you right now y'all crushing this
parenting thing by the way
keep that up man and I went to my room I
put the mask on and I started taking off
my clothes as I had the Batman underwear
you know had the full ensemble my I
turned them around cuz the logo was on
the ass part I want them to know I meant
business you know you got to see it
coming so I went to the front of the
building you know and I opened the door
cause imma get those chatting with the
boys I did the you know the superhero
pose and y'all Batman and I scared
you no more and they just started
laughing
which was fine cuz I could see me get
those face but Carlos still had the
Joker mask on and I don't know if you
seen the movies when jokl add some real
shits about to go down it occurred to me
I had it thought through this plan but
they just started high-fiving each other
talking mad for me yo my little
cousin got balls my little cousins G my
cousin he's scared of nobody Brooklyn
got the old Batman now
that's so great now I've got cocky and
I was in the game man I'm in I went
to school talking mad that day told
all my classmates he'll listen some
go down don't worry buddy I got you
covered
I can't explain it like I take off my
clothes what trust me
it's under control you know now what I
didn't realize is when you tell this
plan to your cousins every time they
were bored which apparently is all the
time for teenage drug dealers they will
come up with wild for me to solve
they're like yo you're my pet Rottweiler
got stuck in your bender building go get
Brooklyn Batman
you're Miss Brown she's hallucinating
again get Brooklyn Batman
Yoda competing drug dealers they're on
our block man get Brooklyn Batman I
installed that last one but I was
entertaining enough to fit on the end
the amicably point being is I was
effective you know but this went on for
a while my rep was now starting to get
out there I was sitting class my last
name is out Monty it starts with ace
always had that front seat by the dog
and the kids would walk by the door and
I were hitting them and one kid was like
yo that's that kid that dinky Batman and
other kid was jumping now that kid is
Batman
she was really locked in but this is
stressful they don't tell you this
you gotta be Batman all the time
he don't get no days off like ever
I got the door I'm a screw be three
plus three is next week like this
is hard me I'm stressed I told my dad's
your pops I can't be Batman on my man
she's too much work I need something
easy like you got with this parenting
thing and he's like listen Gaston you
got over your fear McGee don't Carlos
leaving you alone you could put the mask
away it's not that serious and that's
what I did I retired the mask I'll stop
being Batman and I should have been the
end of it right but superheroes life is
never easy I was 15 my dad had bought a
few more houses you know we didn't
remove the way but we decided to go back
to visit my aunts to lived upstairs
Carlos has gone to jail
you eat dog food down south to avoid
some problems I can't get into that
but he decided to come up the visit no
family occasion now go to mink eat dosa
kill me eat though
not for nothing but why would you keep
scaring the out of me with this
damn mask or the time he's like yo that
wasn't even I did that was you dead
excuse me he said yeah he came up to us
when we when he bought the house and he
was like listen I can't feel a hustle in
front of my house
just make sure my son never want to hang
out with you guys and they interpreted
that is this scare to out of this
little kid everyday now talk to my dad
about your pops this is true you just
scared me on purpose
he said yeah but it worked right and I
learned two things I learned one turns
out wasn't even a joke a mask it was a
buildings mask
I'm not scared of the joke I'm scared of
Tim Burton movies you know I found out
recently it's the same duel playing both
characters I was Michael key and
fighting Michael Keaton
[Applause]
but the second thing I realized this
whole time I was trying to be Batman
my dad is Batman he didn't want any of
the credit he just wanted to get
done
he wanted his soft and she was beautiful
to me you know and now as an adult you
know we work together a lot we have a
good relationship about a month back he
came over to my house apparently one of
my tenants they had a break-in and this
is the building that I live in so he
went over before I dad was at work you
want to console my wife told her about
what we were gonna do the you know
fortified a home make her feel
comfortable and I get home and he's like
yo Gaston come over here for a second
and we walked into my daughter's room to
get some privacy and he's like yo when
when the robbers came in why ain't sure
your wife get the ratchet I'm like yo
I'm not a rapper I don't know what the
ratchet is and then he just casually
walked over to the wall he bang the
window pane and the machete came out
then he went over to the heater one
reached underneath and he pulled out a
gun the Ranchod Gaston I said yo pop
this is my house he's got a gun in my
house and he's like gasps do I keep a
gun in every house I'm like but this is
my daughter's room and he said I know
you're welcome this whole time I wanted
to be Batman it turns out I'm Alfred and
I felt real touched that Batman finally
decided to reveal himself to me thank
you